we talk about CrossFit god bless
CrossFit but my impression of I've been
doing a quiet little study and this is
not scientific but you asked me you want
to see my impression of a CrossFit
athlete and now I'm just recovering from
an injury
I always hurt I'm at this really top top
top competitor and I said I recognize
her of course I go you look like that
crossford and she said I am that's
embarassing you recognize yeah and for
many of reason and I said that I said
what are you doing cuz I'm just coming
back I'd popped a disc out of my neck I
was like well of course you have I said
do you know anybody who's who's not had
an injury and you're a lot of work and
she's like well everybody's hurting him
everybody's basically her yeah the human
body is not made to do 1,000 [ __ ]
curl depressed and that's a million
burpees in a ceiling great brother
you're not sweating again well you've
also been working since what time
anything was not sleeping yeah
you ate a lot hmm you're gonna throw up
mm-hmm yeah I'm sure it's nothing
serious
mmm regular throwing up on a daily basis
with blood with blood is fine okay do
you have sores in your palms and on your
bottom your feet
no well Kevin I'll find them it's
nothing to worry about horns you have
little barnacles you have little bumps
horns and a tail are you growing a small
tail mmm I'd say a large deal okay so
guess what there's nothing wrong with
you what Ben Affleck's new back that's
you whoo it's a hell of a tattoo he
bummed me out do you see this bee
I did I guess I don't know if it's new
but it's the first time people caught it
that's a hell of a tattoo it's like a
Phoenix
I think so right all right dragon
Phoenix Paris it's a phoenix feather
dragon I feel like it's a feather yeah
that's quite good and I was taking
forever to do man that big of a piece on
your hair that's a Japanese that's some
kind of owner when cruza
we have some shitty tattoos but that is
not good ever seen the Yakuza tattoos
like the El from head to toe but the
intricate detail I know that Ben
athletes is the opposite of that he's
not in the Yakuza mm-hmm when you
realized the back to is real and Ben
Affleck was lying Lee said it was for a
movie
was that the face of hers that she did
oh she still can't explain it oh she's
she's just whatever do that she brought
me up on stage Jennifer Garner for this
charity thing I did it she did that face
well what is that
I'm sorry around Photoshop and put
that's my tattoo have to work around the
psoriasis make it tattoo of psoriasis
just a bunch of red bumps no just one
reg we talked the fights to fire and
fights fights
- I'm over Dylan yeah did you see him no
that's why would we talk about I don't
know I just did I did a fight show oh
you did yeah
the only time I've you and Cena oh nice
one okay that's so weren't good either I
want to get your take now then Weaver
Dumas that John got his nephew you know
a grandson grandson yeah he's a fighter
I think he's doing pretty well too I
thought it was mine you think he's doing
well John yeah there's a John for John
Travolta's playing John Gotti in the new
really yeah biopic that'll be
interesting John Gotti was a character
that dude used to that [ __ ] guy used
to bet he was such a compulsive Cajun
want to know so he was such a
competitive gambler he would do [ __ ]
like um there'd be two cockroaches and
he would put crazy money on which
cockroach exhaust and so when they were
they were they had his wiretap you know
I tapped him do you ever hear how they
tapped this [ __ ] guy they got into
the ravenite social club which was right
on Mulberry Street I used to I used to
eat in a place called Cafe Sorrento
right in the area it might be still
there the ravenite social club right a
cop a woman got in she was attractive
very attractive - ended she got in there
she let the dude he used to run the
ravenite Club he'd clean up afterwards
and you do that apparently and it's
pretty pretty stingy she let that guy
bang her and she placed that [ __ ] bug
under the table whatever it takes
whatever it takes brother god bless her
god bless her and that's how they were
able to that was one of the ways they
were able to get like some serious [ __ ]
she got in there she and that guy they
found that that guy had [ __ ] up but
they'd never killed him they're like
it's just the way it is you know what
[ __ ]
they were good good on then Wow yeah
good on them um it's pretty wild the
John Gotti died too in prison right he
was using in Colorado got throat cancer
and [ __ ] that's right yeah he was
desperate to get over there applied for
MMA license
yep he said his wrestling was at a level
seven a couple months you'll get it to a
level nine hilarious painkillers are
different can be a different beast but
again if you're having major surgery oh
oh thank you oh oh you think they're
pushing the agenda go that painkillers
when you get no sighs excuse me sir I
had smoke your weed let me know how that
fixes you know double four yeah I had my
nose and my septum was torn in half and
pushed backwards I had my septum fixed
and that was so painful
when they hadn't unpack your nose it was
the worst and then I had a double hernia
double hernia where they cut into your
body that's a good time actually I'm
sorry they didn't cut it they scoped it
and it still was insanely painful and I
got I will I can't do and a woman goes
this big Jamaican nurse she said you
feel uncomfortable I got Nam all right I
was in so much pain she goes now you
feel uncomfortable they hit me with a
little uh little a little morphine or
whatever it was we you don't become
addicted no you don't but goddamn paging
through that pain can be debilitating
certain pain you're you're not some
people are in pain all the time like
their spinal cord they'd like their
there the nerve roots and their lower
rather have pain like you like off pain
in my neck or whatever my back where
elbows I'm gonna have that to be sick
though at least a pain I can address it
so you take some sort of messing that
will actually kind of help a little bit
when you're sick there's not a whole
light unit you minimize it yeah when you
have the flu and you realize how weak
how like when you have the flu and
you're getting up and throwing up you
realize how vulnerable you are oh my god
I mean you'd say any amount of money to
get rid of it
oh you're just like oh I believe in God
I hey God sorry about all these ants
please please make me better please make
me mad